nothing blows my mind more than the fact that people will literally
refer to abortion as a topic that is like a difference of opinion
50,000 women die every single year from lack of access to abortion
unsafe abortions kill that many women every single year
those are preventable deaths
abortion bans increase the maternal mortality rate by 21%
and here's even more mind blowing part all in pursuit of a policy
abortion bans
that doesn't even reduce the abortion rate
it increases the abortion rate
like all in pursuit of not meeting your policy on goal
that many women every single year
all in pursuit of a policy
that does the exact opposite of what it purports to do
and that's this year's hottest debate